Me voici.
Après avoir obtenu mon diplôme, comme la plupart des mes alter ego,
j'ai choisi de joindre la WWE (Fédération mondiale de lutte).
Me voici, encore une fois.
(Rires)
Vous vous souvenez sans doute de moi aux « Monday Night Raw » en 2002 et 2003.
Je me suis éclaté
à jouer celui qu'on a surnommé affectueusement
Chris Harvard, le snob du Ivy League.
(Rires)
C'était parfait pour moi !
Malheureusement,
mon collègue Bubba Ray Dudley m'a donné un coup de pied à la tête,
et j'ai subi une sévère commotion cérébrale.
Cela a entraîné des symptômes permanents de post-commotion :
migraines constantes, incapacité à dormir, dépression et sentiment d'être embrumé.
Au cours de l'année suivante,
j'ai tenté de trouver des manières de faire disparaître la douleur.
Je n'obtenais pas de réponses des médecins,
ce qui m'a poussé à fouiller dans la litérature médicale.
J'y ai découvert une autre histoire sur les commotions ;
une histoire jamais racontée.
J'ai décidé d'écrire un livre sur le sujet,
« Jeux de tête : la crise des commotions au football », publié en 2006.
Au cours du processus, j'ai appris qu'il ne s'agit pas que de commotions.
J'ai étudié la ETC, la maladie de l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique.
On l'appelait « l'ivresse du poing » car elle affectait seulement les boxeurs.
On savait que les coups répétés à la tête que reçoivent les boxeurs
peuvent causer une dégénérescence du cerveau, qui « pourrit » en somme.
Ils avaient des symptômes
comme des trous de mémoire, des troubles cognitifs,
de la dépression, des troubles de contrôle des pulsions et de l'aggressivité.
Donc, il m'est arrivé ...
d'être blessé au bon moment,
au moment où les deux premiers joueurs de la NFL ont été étudiés pour cette maladie.
Ils en souffraient tous les deux.
Le premier est Mike Webster, 50 ans, qui souffrait déjà de démence.
Le deuxième, Terry Long, avait 45 ans quand il s'est ôté la vie.
Le médecin légiste de Pittsburgh a décidé d'examiner leur cerveau
et a découvert cette maladie.
J'ai écrit un chapitre à ce sujet,
et je croyais que les gens allaient se scandaliser.
Étonnamment, même si les deux premiers cas se sont avérés positifs,
ça n'a jamais fait les manchettes nationales ;
aucun article n'a été écrit sur ces cas de ETC au football.
Le livre est donc publié,
il ne se passe pas grand chose,
et un jour je lis le journal du 20 novembre 2006.
J'y apprends qu'Andre Waters s'est suicidé.
Pour les amateurs de football américain,
Waters est un joueur que j'admirais en grandissant.
Joueur de défense pour les Eagles de Philadelphie,
46 ans, entraîneur de 2ème division,
au moment où il s'est mis un fusil sur la tempe.
Dans l'article on rappelait que son surnom était « Dirty Waters ».
Il était célèbre pour mener avec la tête,
ce qui m'a poussé à vérifier
s'il avait déjà parlé des commotions qu'il a subies.
J'ai trouvé une citation de 1994 dans laquelle Waters disait :
« J'ai arrêté de compter mes commotions à la quinzième.
Je ne disais rien, je reniflais des sels puis retournais au jeu. »
Je me suis dit : « Et s'il avait la ETC, lui aussi ?
Cela aurait-il pu contribuer à ce qui l'a poussé à mettre fin à sa vie ? »
J'ai appelé le docteur qui a fait les premières études et lui ai dit :
« Je crois que vous devriez étudier le cas d'Andre Waters. »
Il m'a répondu : « Ça me ferait plaisir.
Les deux premiers cas sont décédés dans le comté dans lequel je travaille
et je pouvais les étudier dans le cadre de mon travail.
Je ne peux pas le faire avec Waters, car il est mort en Floride.
Si vous voulez que je l'étudie,
trouvez le moyen de m'apporter son cerveau. »
J'ai donc dit : « D'accord.
On s'y prend comment pour obtenir un cerveau ?
(Rires)
Je me suis donc creusé la cervelle et j'ai pensé :
pourquoi ne pas appeler le médecin légiste
qui, je crois, a le cerveau ?
J'ai donc appelé celui-ci en Floride et lui ai dit :
« Vous ne me connaissez pas, mais avez-vous toujours le cerveau de Waters ? »
(Rires)
Il m'a répondu : « oui ».
J'ai dit : « D'accord, mais allez-vous l'étudier pour la ETC ? »
Il a dit non ; il ne croyait pas que c'était une vraie maladie.
J'ai dit : « Si vous ne le faites pas, ça vous embêterait que je le fasse ? »
Il m'a répondu : « Jeune homme,
je ne peux pas vous donner un cerveau.
Il vous faut la permission de la famille.
Si vous obtenez la permission de son plus proche parent,
je vous donnerai son cerveau. »
J'ai dit : « Super ! ».
Puis j'ai réalisé que je devais trouver son proche parent et le lui demander ;
il s'agissait de la mère d'Andre Waters, âgée de 88 ans.
Je me suis assis, ai pris une respiration et me suis demandé :
« Vais-je vraiment téléphoner à une mère endeuillée de 88 ans,
qui vient de perdre son fils par suicide ? »
Presque toutes les fibres de mon être me disaient : « Non, ne fais pas ça.
Ne fais pas vivre ce supplice à cette pauvre femme,
elle a déjà assez souffert. »
Mais une autre voix dans ma tête me disait :
« Tu sais ?
Si des types se suicident à cause de cette maladie
et que nous pouvons l'étudier pour peut-être empêcher que ça se reproduise,
ça vaut parfois le coup d'endurer et de faire quelque chose de pénible. »
Je l'ai donc appelée.
La première fois, pas de réponse.
La deuxième fois, pas de réponse. La troisième... pas de messagerie vocale.
La cinquième fois, on m'a répondu.
Dieu merci, la famille d'Andre Waters a été réceptive à l'appel et m'a dit :
« En vérité, on veut savoir ce qui est arrivé à Andre,
pourquoi il a tant changé dans les 5 dernières années de sa vie. »
Nous avons donc étudié son cerveau,
et il s'est avéré qu'il avait, en effet, la ETC.
Il est le troisième joueur de la NFL à recevoir ce diagnostic.
Voici à quoi ça ressemble.
Il était quelque part entre « léger » et « sévère ».
Nous avons trois joueurs de la NFL ici. Trois sur trois.
Peut-être qu'il est temps de passer aux choses sérieuses.
Il se passe vraiment quelque chose.
J'ai démarré la Fondation « Concussion Legacy »,
j'ai formalisé mon travail,
pour faire plus qu'appeler pour obtenir un cerveau.
Puis, j'ai recherché dans le monde,
pour réunir la meilleure équipe de chercheurs possible.
On s'est associés avec l'Université de Boston
et avec des scientifiques de l'hôpital des Vétérans ici à Boston,
et on a créé une banque de cerveaux.
Si vous voulez traiter les maladies dégénératives du cerveau
commencez par l'étude des cerveaux.
À ce moment-là, nous étions le premier centre au monde à nous intéresser à la ETC
car cette maladie n'avait jamais été étudiée de manière formelle.
On a donc démarré la banque de cerveaux et mon boulot était de les obtenir
pour la banque du docteur Ann McKee, que vous voyez au centre ici.
Nous travaillons aussi avec le Dr Bob Stern et Dr Robert Cantu ;
une équipe scientifique de rêve à laquelle je contribue.
Ma tâche est d'obtenir les cerveaux.
J'ai eu beaucoup de succès au cours des premières années.
Depuis 2007, je débute chaque journée en lisant les rubriques nécrologiques.
Ce n'est pas une vie facile.
C'est difficile pour moi,
et c'est encore plus difficile pour ces familles que je contacte
depuis 10 ans, en leur demandant de me donner le cerveau d'un être cher.
Très tôt dans le processus, alors que ça m'affectait de plus en plus,
je me suis demandé s'il n'y avait pas une autre manière
d'inciter les gens à donner leur cerveau pour la recherche.
Je me suis alors demandé comment créer une culture
de don de cerveaux dans ce pays.
Et si c'était la norme pour un athlète de donner son cerveau après son décès ?
J'ai donc créé un registre pour le don de cerveaux.
J'ai commencé à demander aux athlètes
de promettre publiquement de donner leur cerveau à la science.
Tout cela a débuté en 2009, avec un joueur de hockey.
L'une de mes premières promesses a été celle d'un ancien hockeyeur de Harvard,
Noah Welch, qui jouait alors dans la Ligue nationale.
Ça a pris du temps pour expliquer aux gens de quoi il s'agissait.
Quand ça a fait la une des journaux,
« Noah Welch donnera son cerveau à la science, »
le lendemain, dans le vestiaire,
un de ses coéquipiers l'a pris à part et a dit :
« J'ai entendu que tu allais donner ton cerveau à la science. »
Il a dit : « Ouais. »
Il a dit : « Wow. Tu vas manquer combien de parties ? »
(Rires)
Une histoire véridique !
Nous avons eu beaucoup de succès --
plus de 2 500 athlètes se sont portés volontaires.
Ils ont reçu une carte de don qu'ils ont dans leur porte-monnaie.
Voici la mienne. J'étais bien évidemment le premier ; elle porte le numéro 01.
Et je vais faire don de mon cerveau.
On a eu la chance d'obtenir l'accord de Brandi Chastain,
l'icône du football féminin,
du pilote de NASCAR Dale Earnhardt Jr.
Il y a deux semaines, Nick Buoniconti, intronisé au Temple de la Renommée
et souffrant de démence, a signé.
C'est merveilleux !
Et le plus fantastique,
c'est qu'on a été en mesure de changer la manière d'obtenir les cerveaux.
On ne contacte plus les familles, ce sont elles qui nous appellent.
Nos téléphones sonnent sans arrêt !
Ainsi, je peux me concentrer sur ces informations,
et sur comment trouver une voie vers un traitement,
et aussi sur la prévention ;
ça m'a grandement facilité la vie.
Voici quelques-uns des grands titres que nous avons obtenus au fil des ans,
sur des athlètes promettant de donner leur cerveau.
Le problème se situe dans ce que nous avons appris.
Quand on a commencé,
seulement 45 cas de cette maladie
avaient été étudiés dans les banques de cerveaux, dans le monde.
Depuis ce temps, nous avons obtenu 500 cerveaux
et sur ce nombre, plus de 300 étaient atteints de la ETC.
Pour mettre cela en perspective,
le reste du monde n'a étudié que 100 cerveaux depuis le début du projet.
Ce que nous avons découvert est terrifiant.
Certains d'entre vous avez peut-être vu la une
du New York Times en juillet.
Une étude récente que nous avons publiée
a démontré que des 111 premiers joueurs de la NFL examinés,
110 ont un résultat positif pour la ETC.
Sur les 53 premiers joueurs de football américain universitaires étudiés,
48 ont été diagnostiqués avec ETC.
C'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète énormément.
Donc, je me concentre maintenant
sur ce que nous pouvons faire pour traiter cette maladie.
On ne peut pas encore diagnostiquer la ETC chez les patients vivants,
et il n'y aura pas de traitement pharmaceutique
au cours des cinq prochaines années.
Il s'agit d'une très longue lutte.
Mais notre fondation est là pour non seulement faciliter ce travail,
c'est le plan à long terme, mais on peut aussi le prévenir à court terme.
On peut prévenir la maladie,
simplement en arrêtant de frapper les gens à la tête.
Honnêtement, arrêtons de frapper les enfants à la tête.
C'est une mauvaise idée de frapper un enfant de 5 ans à la tête
500 fois par an.
Ça peut entraîner le développement de cette maladie.
Nous avons donc du pain sur la planche,
mais j'ai bon espoir que nous sommes en voie de trouver un traitement.
J'espère que vous comprenez maintenant un peu mieux mon histoire.
Maintenant que nous nous connaissons un peu mieux,
laissez-moi vous poser la question :
« Puis-je avoir votre cerveau ? »
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)